playtime shouldn't be hard work but for
sam bowen and her nine-year-old daughter
lucy finding an accessible playground
with safe equipment is an ordeal
it's very um
very lonely experience really coming to
a playground we see other kids and your
kid can't go on anything
the nearest accessible playground is a
15-minute drive from their home and even
then some of the most exciting equipment
is out of bounds
to go to a place and then go well you
can look and you can you know what fun
are you gonna have watching other
children playing if you can't take part
yourself it's cruel actually
the disability equality charity scope
says its research shows 10 percent of
parents of disabled children didn't feel
their child was safe using inaccessible
equipment and the same number said their
child hurt themselves because of it
the charity says accessible grounds
would make a world of difference to
these families
families with disabled children already
face so many challenges in their
everyday life and one challenge that
they're facing at the minute is not
being able to enjoy this core community
space of a local playground and feeling
included in their communities
for local authorities equality isn't
swings and roundabouts councils are
subject to the public sector equality
duty which means they have to work to
advance equality
a government spokesperson said where a
local council is responsible for a
playground they must carefully consider
how to make them inclusive and
accessible
we have made available an extra 3.7
billion pounds to councils this year so
they can deliver vital services for the
people of their communities and respond
to local priorities in their areas
including playgrounds
scope has called on the government to
create a fund just for inclusive
playgrounds it says that money can
create simple changes to make them open
to all children
sadia chowdhury sky news